today. Uh Pamela Geller, who many of you
know, editor and publisher of atlas
shrugs.com. Um she has also founded and
is the executive director of Stop
Islamization of America, Sio, and of the
Freedom Defense Initiative, FDI. and
she's also a regular columnist for
Andrew Bipart's big government big
journalism the American thinker and
other publications
um I think you all know if you don't
that Pamela is a very brave
individual who's made the decision to
stand up to what she sees to be u the
encroachment of
uh militant Islam in our country and
around the world and the danger that it
poses to our society and our children.
She's she should be a hero to all of us.
Whether you agree or disagree with
Pamela Geller on any one thing or
another or anyone else, it doesn't
matter. We have a society that permits
us to say things uh and to be critical
of elements. It's disscent is the
foundation of our freedom of speech
rights in this country. After September
11th, Pamela immersed herself uh to get
a full understanding of geopolitics and
Islam. You know, I've had a chance to
talk with Pamela casually at several
events around the country when we've
been together, and I couldn't help but
realize that this is but for what's
happened in this country on 911. An
ordinary person with daughters trying to
raise a family in this world and like
many other people woke up on 912, 2001,
decided she was going to learn
everything she could and make a
difference about it. this book, what she
does every day, uh the battles that she
has, the courage that she's shown to get
out in front of u the public and say
things that many people are afraid to
say as she's been condemned for. She's
put herself on the line on national
television. Uh she's been judged before
she hasn't even a chance to open her
mouth. Very few people like Pamela
Geller. She's a hero of our time and uh
we should all be emulating her if we can
even in our daily lives in little ways
to stand up for truth. I think uh
something emblematic of her
u she wrote on her blog just a few days
ago after she'd appeared with uh Geraldo
Rivera who really was setting her up to
be uh an extremist on an issue that
she's been extremely reasonable about.
And she goes on to say, um, it was that
kind of night. Heraldo didn't seem to
care how nonsensical, rude, and ignorant
he had to be to do it. He was just
determined to portray me and those who
agree with me as extreme. It was yet
another example of how out of touch the
American people and the mainstream media
has become. And here's the part that I
think is really interesting, and I I
think that you should all hear this
because I think this is what we're all
up against. Well, Haraldo, we are not
all extremists. We are not going away
either. Defending America is not
extreme. Truth has become extreme. Truth
is a new hate speech. The lies that
Gerald Heraldo and others like you tell
about us and the boxes you push us into
become more obvious to people every
day. This is such important wisdom and
this is a tough cookie, a very high
intellect and and moral values. someone
I am extremely pleased that could be
here with us today. Thank you very
[Music]
much. Good afternoon. I want to thank
Craig Snder, Mike Finch, and the David
Howard Center for even hosting this and
supporting my work, Robert's work at a
time when uh the voices against uh
Islamization and jihad are increasingly
marginalized, smeared, and
defamed. So, thank you for your bravery
and the work that you do. I I think it's
fitting that we are here at the Union
Club. Established in 1862 as a patriotic
society in support of President
Lincoln's efforts to preserve the Union.
And here we are hundreds of years later,
his dream fully realized, the election
of a black
president. And I wonder what President
Lincoln would
say. Uh first of all, the book uh is the
definitive work on President Obama. Now,
you may think you know President Obama,
you don't know President Obama. Uh he's
seniorly presiding over the decline of
America. Not only presiding over it, but
aiding and abetting it. I know that
these are these are harsh words, but the
reality is what it is. I mean, you can
avoid reality, but you cannot avoid the
consequences of avoiding reality. Um and
he's an internationalist and he would
like to see us as one of many you know
nations under the guise of
internationalism. His uh appointments
his adviserss all subscribe to
internationalism whether it's Harold Co
legal adviser for the state department
um Alena Kagan
soayor Samantha Pace the list is on and
on. Um I I'm not going to go into finite
detail, but in broad sweeping strokes we
see he has abandoned our
allies and he's aiding in abetting our
enemies. To what end? I cannot tell you.
And for me the most critical issue of
course is freedom of speech because
freedom of speech is the line with
sound. Without freedom of speech,
peaceful men have no choice but to get
violent. There's no alternative. And we
see time and again here it he
co-sponsored a resolution at the UN uh
to restrict free speech not to defame
Islam. Uh that's the first time in in in
history a US president has ever signed
on to a restriction of free speech. Um
and we see an increasing uh
Islamization in America. One only has to
look at for example uh the ground zero
mosque. Now, we have to talk about the
Grand Zero Mosque for myriad reasons.
Um, because so many uh reverbs,
reverberations from this one terrible
and it is attack. It's an attack. It's a
It's a jihadi attack on America. It's a
stealth attack. Um, you have a president
who stands up at a very glamorous iftar
dinner to sanction the ground zero
mosque under a false narrative, a false
pretense of religious freedom. Now, it
has nothing to do with religious
freedom, just so that you know. Nothing.
And at no time did Robert Spencer or
myself ever or those that are fighting
it ever seek to a bridge the first
amendment ever invoke religious
freedom. It is common
decency. It is human
compassion. I mean the Japanese never
asked to build a Shinto shrine at Pearl
Harbor. Nor would they ever.
And when uh many people many Jewish
people uh reacted uh fiercely uh towards
the Carmelite convict outside of Oshvitz
um the pope withdrew not because he had
to withdraw not because there was a
German because it was the common decent
thing to do. So just on that level so
you have the president of the United
States. Now you can say oh he's a purist
you know he's an ideologue. Well, he is,
but if he was a purist, why did he come
out against the free speech of the Quran
burning? Now, let me say this. I don't
think Quran burning is a good idea. I
think the antidote to bad speech is more
speech, is more discussion, is give and
take, and the truth will add. But it's
it's protected speech. And who died and
made the the Quran the Holy Grail? Don't
burn the
Quran. What is that? But you burn a
flag, you burn a Bible, you can burn
anything. But don't burn the Quran.
Excuse me. Sorry. And everybody buys
into it. Oh, nothing. Don't, you know,
uh, look, the interesting thing to me
about that story
was, a fringe
pastor tweets something very stupid.
Yes. And the media is on it like white
on rice. They are all descending upon
some backwater in Florida, camping out
at the French pastor's uh, church.
Interesting, right? Why? I'll tell you
why. Because the ground zero mosque
became a national story and an
international story with no mainstream
media. It became the number one story.
And everyone said, "She did it. She
ginned them up." And I'm going to tell
you something. It's very flattering.
Thank you very
much. But it's impossible. I've been
doing what I've been doing for years
since 2005. Studying first and then
started writing in 2005. Every day at
least 10 times a day I update atmas
shrugs. So why this story? Why didn't I
do this a year ago? Why not do this two
years ago? Let me tell you, there are a
million stories I would have put on the
front page. I would have put Amina and
Sarah say on the front
page. I would have put Molly Norris on
the front page. I would have put
Shanksville on the front page. the
Flight 93 memorial. What I'm saying is
is that they're looking to demonize me
and therefore everyone that's associated
with me is demonized. Do you agree with
that? You're a racist Islamic
anti-Muslim
bigot. Now, some interesting things come
out of this story. First of all, it's a
good thing. It's a good thing for a
myriad reasons. A, because the American
people are seeing for the first time the
stealth jihad up in their face. How are
they seeing it? because they have in
their daily life made accommodations to
Islam in the daily social fabric of
their lives. They have, you see, they
mosque the workplace. You see, cashiers
at Walmart and Target won't handle meat.
It has to be the halal, you know. Um, a
woman gets fired from rising star
industries because she was eating a
bacon, lettuce, and tomato sandwich in
the company cafeteria. Not a Muslim
company. Uh the US Treasury Department
was giving seminars in Sharia Finance a
week after they nationalized the banks.
yada yada yada yada. Do not insult
Islam. Do not defame Islam. Do not run
the Danish
cartoons. Uh the producers from South
Park have a death threat on their head
because they dare put Muhammad in a
hugging bear costume. They actually
bleeped out the word Muhammad. All
right? And the people know this and they
say, "Well, we don't want to offend
anybody, you know." So, here you have a
15story triumphal mosque on a building
that was destroyed in the attacks of
9/11. Not 600 ft, not 600 ft, not 2 and
a half blocks away. Not that building is
ground
zero. Why
there? That's the essential question.
Why there? Uh for healing, you have
healing and outreach. outreach and
healing. Okay, so let's take this
dishonest imam at his
word. Indulge me. If it were true, it
was about healing and outreach. Look
what it's caused. Such discord, such
divisiveness, such unhappiness, such
grief. The 911 families pleading with
them not to build this triumphal mosque.
And I have to say that I find I imam
Raou and Daisy Khan's callous dismissive
callous dismissiveness of the pain in
the grief they're causing radically
intolerant. And the American people see
this. So at first every single time they
had me
on every single time I would speak first
and then they'd have some Islamic
supremacist come on destroy me and on to
the next one. Then I said, "Look, I I
said to CNN, I said, "Listen, you're
going to have me on you. I don't go
first and the next guy comes on and
says, "Pat McGill is a racist Islam. I'm
a boy bigot." So we would debate and I
would get into the ring, never with the
same guy. Never. You know how you watch
sports tapes, you know how you sports
teams or fighters, they watch the tapes
of the guy they're going to compete with
or the team so you can get a sense of
their game, you know? I debated
Palestinian hip hoppers. I debated
Muslim Brotherhood. I debated Cale. I
debated uh Colombia School of Journalism
professor. Um I Yeah. And then when I
wrote I said I wrote, "Look at this.
Look how they never have the same person
on to debate me. What are they so afraid
of? They know my game. My game is the
truth. That's why they can't
[Applause]
[Music]
win." So they had it like debate me a
second time. Ibrahim Raymond of the
Muslim American Society. Muslim American
Society was established in 1993 at
Republic face of the Muslim Brotherhood.
This is all documented. This is another
thing she's making this stuff up. And I
say it was entered into evidence in the
largest uh terror funding trial in US
history, the uh you know Holyland trial.
Um the media the media will not do its
work. The media will not do its work.
It's like the med it's like the New York
Times is doing the profile piece on me.
Uh don't ask. And they can say, "Well,
how how much money if you got $20 from
here and and someone gave you $25 from
here and how much money?" They want to
know every every single cent that I'm
getting. Trust me, there's no money in
what I'm doing. But look at this. Did
they look at Raul like this? Did they
look at he's a slum lord? Did they look
at the fact that he got $2 million to do
repairs on his slums, his unlivable
slums, toilet water, vermin, roaches,
broken? Got $2 million. Never used the
money. Never. Yeah. Where's Where's the
New York Times on that? He's a prominent
member of the Pana organization, the
single largest financeier of the ter
Turkish terrorist group
IIAH. They launched the jihad flotilla
to provoke the tiny Jewish state into
defending itself so that it would be a
public relations disaster. And it was. I
ran on my site audio, exclusive audio of
him speaking. And I'm sure you heard
when when he said that the US has more
Muslim blood on its hands than than than
uh al-Qaeda has the blood of innocent
non-Muslims. Code word innocent
non-Muslim code. Because if you if you
read the Quran and believe there's no
such thing as an innocent Muslim, if you
were innocent non-Muslim, if you were an
innocent non-Muslim, you'd be a
Muslim. So he's as radical as
Osama. He said that we're an accessory
to 911, that he was made in the USA,
Osama bin Laden. And all of this is is
it's sanctioned. And what I what we've
witnessed here is a we can make things
happen without the media. Forget the
media. This is important. How did the
ground zero mosque become a big story? I
had been writing about it in December.
It came back on the radar screen in
April, May because the demies on the uh
Bloomberg Bloomberg's toolbox, that's
what I call them, voted unanimously,
don't you love that? Unanimously. No
disscent. um uh to approve the plan even
though they really didn't need approval.
They wanted the sanctioning of the
political system which they
have and Robert and I did a rally and I
expected a couple hundred people. There
was upwards of 8,000 people there all
visav Jihad watch and
atlas and then
somebody took pictures from a blog of uh
looking at the left which is a he's a
photojournalist. He took amazing
pictures that day and um without a link,
without a story and they sent it around
to their list and it said mystery
rally and it started to go. I started to
see it in my email box six seven times a
day. That's how that became a story just
so that you know and the reason why I'm
telling you that this is because every
action that you
take there's a reaction. Everything that
you do contributes to the greater good,
to the fight. I hear all the time, well,
one person. No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
If history has taught us anything, it's
that the individual can change the
course of human
[Applause]
events. And we're living in an age where
you have as a president a statist, a
collectivist. And this is the most
deeply troubling thing of all because
the basic founding principle of America
was individual rights. The
individual everything great and noble
and just and magnificent that we
achieved was a result of the fidelity of
that
principle. And this is why he must be
stopped. He must be stopped. You must
get out the vote in November. You
must I mean it's not just the you know
when I say he's pro-Islam look you don't
take NASA kill the space program kill
the shuttle and redirect their efforts
to extol the work of the Muslim
world run that by me
again I mean but it's one thing after
another speech in
Cairo was in his depending upon who
writes the history books is a defining
moment in US history and to equate the
viol violation of women women's rights
in America to the violation of women's
rights in the Muslim world takes an
incredible amount of contempt for human
life
and contempt for the American people.
So, I'm going to turn the mic over to to
Robert Spencer. I know I should have
spent more time on the book, but the
mosque issue is a critical issue because
despite getting in the ring, and it's
always getting in the ring, you know,
it's like I hear it. Ding ding ding ding
ding throw, you know.
Um, we're talking about things that
people never
hear. Building triumphal mosques on the
cherish sites of conquered lands, site
dome of the rock, the sight, St. Sophia,
even the Taj Mahal, you know. Um the
fact that what about what is driving you
know the these extremists couple of
extremists I got to tell you these are
six very busy guys
okay to over 20,000 attacks since 9/11
all with the every single one of those
attacks with the impromater of a Muslim
cleric what's being done what's being
done to expune the Quran of its violent
texts these are things that you never
hear on television ever that I would say
and what I Love I love when they come on
the next night to debate me. Do you hear
what she said? Yeah, she said that it's
original Islam. Well, how ridiculous is
that? But they wouldn't have me on.
They'll have six guys on to to rip apart
what I said. But I'm telling you that
something critical. We reached critical
mass. The latest poll showed an
overwhelming number of the American
people do not trust the media. Now, let
me tell you why that's huge.
[Music]
It's huge because if you don't have
that, what do you got? That's all you
got. That's why I'm so, you know, I the
blog and that's another thing very
quickly. They never mention the blog is
Pamela Keller. Stop the Islamization of
America. Never the blog, never the book.
And we send them the art. We send them I
have Simon cha sends them all the
private. I've been doing so America is
three months old. Atlas from 2005. Atlas
is my heart, my soul. It's like my
living room. Sit down. Let's talk about
what's happening. You know, and so I do
say things that are controversial. But
it's what I would say to you. It's what
I would say to you. I'd say, "Yeah, he's
the manorian candidate. My articles, the
book, that's the work." But you see me
work. It's my
workshop. And you know, they will go
through 20,000 posts to find something
that I didn't say.
takes an awful lot of imagination. Um,
so get out the vote. You have to get out
the vote in in in November. You have to
send around. You have to be the media.
You're the media. I've seen it happen. I
do more foreign press on Ground Zero
Mosque than I do
national. This has distilled the entire
war to its essential oils.
No conflating this with the nonsense. Oh
yeah, this this is
peace. This is so in your face that
people without even a cursory knowledge
of Islam say this is wrong. This is
wrong. And the more they show
themselves, oh, I'm now it's not
healing. Now I'm standing between you
and the extremists. Get out of the
way. Thank you very much.
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow.
I don't know, Robert. That's a tough act
to follow.